¿También entró en el gueto?
Seguro.
Allá no era uno, mire, afuera.
¿Quién sé, mire, que es judío, mire?
No, pero es casa afuera, todo en gueto.
¿Y dónde vivía usted en el gueto?
En una casa.
Ya estaba desocupado.
Por tanto, gente se quemaron.
Quedaron casas vacías.
Y allá hicieron gueto.
¿Y con quién vivía usted en la casa?
Yo con mi hermano, con mi señora,
con la cuñada,
y otro hermano.
Una casa grande.
¿Grande era la casa?
Sí, era una casa grandísima.
¿Y había doctores en el gueto?
¿Enfermería, farmacia, todo lo que quisieran?
¿Qué era?
No era nada, señora.
Nada, mire.
¿Quién aguantó?
Aguantó.
Murió.
Puede ser tu frase, mire.
Cada día tomaron, mire, vodka.
¿Estaba de vodka?
Estaba de vodka.
Dicen mañana vamos a morir.
Vendieron hasta último camisa.
Aquel que estaba de camisa.
Vamos a morir así, así, la vacuna.
¿Y usted qué pensaba?
Era una cosa.
Eran doce muchachos
que huyeron
y se pusieron partesanas.
No, ¿qué pensaba usted estar allí en el gueto?
¿Cómo yo podía dejar a mi señora tanto que yo luchaba?
Mi señora, para mi pantalla, no era persona.
Era demasiado encima.
Yo nunca le quise dejar a mi señora.
O vivir junto o morir junto.
Fin.
¿Cuánto tiempo estuvo en el gueto?
Guetos me estaban
ocho meses.
¿Qué comía?
Yo puedo decir
que yo comía de todo
y mi gente comía de todo que trabajaba conmigo.
¿Por qué?
Te voy a decir una cosa.
Tengo que decir, mire,
no hice cosas correctas,
lo tengo que declarar.
Para entrar en la oficina de Antoneski, que yo tenía antes,
como entrar en cielo.
Y yo entré, con permiso,
de Alemanchik,
dos amigos.
Él me dio permiso que tiene que mandar 400 metros árboles
para tanto tal tal tal para hacer para puentes.
A mí sobraban tablas
y yo vendí campesinos.
Yo no quise dinero.
Que me traigan comida.
Cada campesino
que yo dio tablas
me trajo comida.
Que preguntan
¿Adónde tú compraste?
En Zeya de Archeológicos.
¿Qué te vendió?
Nada más.
Me sacan, me matan como un perro.
Pasó ocho meses.
Yo no sé si es una cosa de Dios o tiene que pasar así, mire.
A nadie me preguntaron.
Nunca.
Hasta fin
cuando
fui liquidado del gueto.
Mis 22 personas vivían bien.
¿Cómo fui liquidado del gueto?
Antes de eso, ¿cómo eran las relaciones
de la gente no judía con los judíos del gueto?
No encontramos.
Estaban cerrados.
No tenían derecho a salir del gueto.
Pero no les ayudaban.
La gente no judía, no les daba comida.
Nada.
¿Cómo gente tenían?
Un palto.
Unos zapatos.
Entonces con cuchillos se hicieron entre tablas.
Y entonces por eso metieron leche, pan.
Venían hasta último mellas de pie.
No eran negocios.
No para polacos y no para alemanes y no para judíos.
¿Y usted se llevó algo consigo de su casa?
¿Ropa? ¿Joyas?
¿De lo que usted tenía?
Olvídese de joyas.
¿Qué joyas eran?
¿Qué tenía con usted en el gueto?
¿Qué se había llevado?
¿De su casa originaria de Valdava?
¿Qué había llevado al gueto?
Antes de que lo metieran al gueto se trajo...
Una cama con las sábanas, con la almohada.
Una mesa con cuatro sillas.
No, pero ¿de sus efectos personales?
Mire, allá se usaba una camisa un mes.
Con mi señora que estaba en la casa, que no tenía su shine.
Arbeitshine.
Que esta señora no quiere trabajar.
¿Usted me entiende?
Ya me hicieron...
Alemanche que ya me arregló todo con la recursos de mi gente.
Entonces ella me la daba, la noche me la daba.
Se acabó y en la mañana ya me puso.
Eso no hay pregunta.
¿Cómo se bebía?
No se puede contestar.
No hay contestación.
¿Y cómo era el sistema de entrada y salida del gueto?
¿Le pedían pases? ¿Cómo funcionaba la guardia?
No era salida.
¿Para trabajar?
Yo tenía un servicio especial para mis obreros para hacer de todo lo que me arregló Alemanche.
¿Usted me entiende?
Era el único.
El único.
¿Qué fuerza?
Esta me ayudó.
No se puede decir.
¿Y cómo eran los horarios?
Ahorita yo le digo una cosa.
Le digo muchas cosas que usted tampoco nos preguntó.
Tengo que renovar una cosa.
En tiempo del gueto...
salieron con mi señora
y me agarraron.
Me agarraron.
Formaron un cliente de personas
y me mandaron para Sobibor.
Eso es durante el gueto.
Pero antes de llegar a Sobibor, vamos a ver un poquito lo del gueto, ¿no?
Eso fue después. Sobibor fue después del gueto.
Existía hasta el último momento.
Cuando yo estaba en el gueto,
tenía permiso.
Como mi señora tenía signo de médico,
no puedo decir por qué yo me salí con ella y agarraron a nosotros.
Me dijeron una palabra muy fea.
¡Das y scheiße!
Eso no vale nada.
Me agarraron 500 personas del gueto
y me llevaron.
Conmigo se quedaron en el gueto
para que me tomen.
Eso fue antes de liquidar el gueto.
Antes de liquidar el gueto.
Pero antes de llegar allá,
¿cuáles eran los horarios del trabajo?
¿Usted salía a qué hora del gueto?
No, siempre a las ocho.
Y me quedaron a las cinco para el gueto.
Y ese era un sábado que no se trabajaba.
Sábado no se trabajaba.
Yo salí con mi señora y me agarraron
y me dijeron que ese permiso que tiene es scheiße.
Así que no vale nada.
Y me mandaron 500 personas.
¿En el gueto cómo los trataban los guardias?
Los guardias.
En el gueto no estaban nada.
Rodando.
Afuera.
¿Vigilando?
Vigilando.
¿Y hubo alguna vez que mataron a alguien?
¿Tomaron represalias?
Tomaron represalias.
Muchos, mire.
Que unos arañazos que tenían hambre, mire.
O morir.
O comer.
Brincaron por todo, mire.
Y cuando, mire, era todo.
Luces como esta.
Estaban diciendo.
Rodondo.
La vieron, mire.
Uno murió.
¿Y el Judenrat seguía existiendo?
El Judenrat.
Ya.
Ya estaba todo liquidado.
Cuando hicieron el gueto ya fue liquidado todo.
Ya no era Judenrat.
¿Quiénes conformaban el Judenrat?
El SS.
Ichki.
¿Pero quién, qué judíos estaban en el Judenrat?
Fayvol Legaman.
Hermanos Abramovich.
Haskel Bartik.
Y en el gueto usted observaba el Shabbat, el castillo.